Robert Habeck oder wie ich ihn gerade
nenne Robert planlos man bemerkt ja das
Chaos und Wirtschaftsministerium als
Bürger sehr genau ich weiß nicht ob sie
sich auch wundern aber ich frage mich
schon seit längerem was ist eigentlich
aus der gasumlage geworden also bis
heute hat man darüber eigentlich so gar
nichts mehr vom Wirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck gehört heute wurde dann
bekannt gegeben dass die Zahlung der
gasumlage auf Ende Oktober verschoben
wird der Beginn des Konzepts steht aber
für den ersten Oktober fest dass viel
hinter der Verschiebung ist natürlich
einfach Robert Habeck will sich Zeit
verschaffen läuft es also vielleicht gar
darauf hinaus dass es gar keine
gasumlage geben wird hier verstehen Sie
mich bitte richtig ich fände es
großartig von Robert Habeck wenn er
zugibt dieses Projekt war misst Murks
bleibt Murks ich lasse es fallen aber
anstatt das zu tun zögert Robert Habeck
ist immer weiter hinaus obwohl
offensichtlich ist dass er mit der
Planung überfordert ist und der Heilmann
die Frage geht natürlich an sie was hört
man denn so im Bundestag da gibt es ja
auch immer flurf wie auch überall sonst
wie steht's denn um die gasumlage da
muss man gar nicht Flurfunk hören wir
haben letzte Woche eine Abstimmung
gemacht das haben wir beantragt dass die
gasumlage fallen gelassen wird der hat
die Mehrheit der Ampel hat diesen Antrag
abgelehnt
die diskabinett hat letzte Woche ein
paar Korrekturen beschlossen
insbesondere soll damit erreicht werden
dass Unternehmen den sehr gut geht das
Geld wenigstens nicht bekommen sollen
das ist zwar richtig aber der Rest
bleibt falsch
aber die klare erklärte wählende Ampel
ist dass sie bei dieser gasumlage
bleiben was besonders absurd ist weil
sie ja jetzt offensichtlich darüber
reden dass sie uniper verstaatlichen
wollen was wir richtig finden nur
darüber muss der Gasmarkt stabilisiert
werden und nicht damit dass 34
Milliarden Euro von auch den Zuschauern
hier abgenommen wird die beschlossen
wurde kommen wir noch einmal doch zum
Flurfunk zurück weil ich frage mich
natürlich jetzt schon als als Bürgerin
es wurde jetzt erstmal verschoben die
Auszahlung
die Stadtwerke sagt die Stadtwerke
müssen das hier ihren Kunden gegenüber
abrechnen und die haben sich alle
beklagt dass sie das nicht schaffen und
deswegen kriegen die jetzt vier Wochen
länger Zeit es auszurechnen das ist
leider kein Indiz dafür dass sie sie
fallen lassen also sie glauben die
gasumlage wird kaum mehr habe wird eine
Pläne um 180 Grad drehen dann wird sie
kommen und sie ist falsch und sie wird
beklagt werden also da wird es Klagen
dagegen geben und den ich sehr gute
Aussichten gebe und dann ist das Chaos
endgültig für meine These dass er habe
überfordert ist scheint ihnen das auch
so oder glauben sie das nicht also ich
bin jetzt kein Oppositionspolitiker der
allen Politikern erstmal auch wenn sie
von der Konkurrenz sind von vornherein
Unfähigkeit unterstellt ich bin bei der
gasumlage hart anderer Meinung
aber wir haben eine sehr schwere
Energiekrise dafür können sie nichts und
deswegen versuche ich es eher
konstruktiv als destruktiv aber
ich bin jetzt mal sehr gespannt ob sie
die energiepreisbremse richtig
hinkriegen das nämlich auch noch nicht
Opposition hier heute Abend wie sehen
Sie das denn ist ja habe ich mit der
Planung der gasumlage überfordert wie
sieht die Lage aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium also Herr Habeck
ist
schwer
gebeutelt sagen wir es mal so weil er
eben auch in seinem Haus
keine Leute hat die ihnen richtig
beraten wie er vorzugehen hat er hat es
selber eingeräumt die gasseumlage er hat
ja gesagt das waren seine Leute die das
verbockt haben das fand ich bemerkens
Wirtschaftsministerium wenn ich richtig
informiert bin von
Politikern soll er erstmal die Leute
ausgewechselt haben als er kam also er
hat wohl nicht sämtlich also
Staatssekretär das ist normal ist ja
eine andere politische Farbe da ist ja
von schwarz auf grün aber eben auch
Leute die darunter sitzen und man muss
eben sagen hat er auch ausgewechselt er
selber gilt ja als Vertreter der real
los also ein Pragmatiker die die
darunter sind die Staatssekretäre sind
alle strammen grün links teilweise eben
auch wirklich von den NGOs geholt
teilweise aus seiner Partei aber eben
die sollten so ein bisschen die Brücke
zwischen dem er ist ein bisschen
pragmatisch unterwegs und holt damit ja
auch mehr Stimmen und seine seine Truppe
hält die die
Basis zufrieden das ist nun mit diesem
ganzen Energiebereich komplett aus dem
Lot geraten weil er braucht bräuchte
jetzt eigentlich welche die eben ganz
klar auch dem Markt erklären und sagen
was man machen kann und was nicht und
bei Gas ist es so da ist jetzt eine
Expertengruppe also nachdem er die
gasseumlage in seinem eigenen Haus
gemacht hat und damit eine Bauchlandung
hingelegt hat extrem Protest von allen
Seiten
nachgebessert hat aber immer noch ist es
morgens will er nun die Frage im wie
deckelt man da was was kann man da
machen man hat sich ja beim Strom
so ein bisschen vorgewagt da ist es
relativ klar wie das aussehen soll beim
Gas kann man das so nicht machen also
halten wir eigentlich einmal fest nicht
nur Robert Habeck hat wenig planen
sondern auch nicht die besten Leute um
sich geschadet wo man jetzt davon
ausgeht da ist das beste
wirtschaftsexpertise des Landes
versammelt und die Wirtschaftsweisen die
ja die Bundesregierung wirtschaftlich
beraten haben jetzt sich zusammen in
einem
sonderappell hingestellt und gesagt es
muss dringend jetzt was gemacht werden
das ist noch nicht Gast das ist eine
extra Thema aber eben um die
Energiepreise und vor allen Dingen die
Drohne Knappheit
abzuwenden die AKWs länger laufen lassen
nicht nur eben als Notreserve das sei
die schlechteste alleine
junge nicht geweiter wenn Sie das jetzt
hören auch als Bürger wie sehen Sie denn
die Lage im Wirtschaftsministerium fühlt
man sich da gut wirtschaftlich beraten
geschützt
ich kann dazu nur sagen das sind
Dilettanten am Werk und ich kann ihnen
auch nicht zustimmen dass die nicht für
die Energiekrise können sondern meiner
Meinung nach können die sehr viel dafür
weil die Energiekrise gab es schon vor
der ukraine-krise wir hatten ab
September 21 gasmangel wieso haben wir
gasmangel weil es die drei Jahre davor
wurden in Europa ungefähr 20 Gigawatt an
Kohle Kohlekraftwerken abgeschaltet und
als dann nach Corona sich die Konjunktur
erholt hat da brauchte man mehr Strom
und dann musste man Gaskraftwerke die
eigentlich für die für die Spitzenlast
da waren in der Grundlast laufen lassen
und seitdem war die Krise da und seitdem
hat man die Augen verschlossen man hat
dann Ende 21 die ersten Kernkraftwerke
abgeschaltet und jetzt will man den
nächsten abschalten also mal so richtig
die Wirtschaft vor die Wand fahren und
da ist natürlich die Union auch nicht
ganz unschuldig weil ich meine die
vorige Regierung hat uns das Dilemma
eigentlich hinterlassen dass wir mit
eben einem Ausstieg einem gleichzeitigen
Ausstieg aus Kohle und Atomkraft
eigentlich schon ganz offen sehr
ungünstigen Pfad begeben haben also
selbst wenn die ukraine-krise da stimme
ich durchaus zu
jetzt nicht gekommen wäre hätten wir ein
Problem wir hätten uns dann immer auf so
Ausland verlassen können jetzt ist aber
ein ganz Europa das die Energie knapp
das heißt fast alle EU-Länder sagen uns
also wenn ihr euch in eine derart
schlechte Lage gegeben habe dass ihr nun
ganz besonders schlecht
vorbereitet seid
ist erstmal sich jeder selbst der
Nächste der schauen wir doch jetzt mal
bei Heimann kurz nach zur sind ja als
Oppositionspolitiker sehr gnädig habe
ich heute abend gelernt aber Sie können
ihm ihre eigenen Regierung die ja auch
lange regiert hat die Union bis ins
Gericht gehen vielleicht ja kann ich
auch aber noch mal zusammengefasst weil
das so immer eine Robert Habeck hat
nicht regiert und wenn haben dann wir
und vor allen Dingen der
Wirtschaftsminister Gabriel also die die
Fehler sind vielfältig gemacht worden
sie jetzt ich finde wenn das auch nicht
nicht also man sollte es gibt genug zu
kritisieren da muss man jetzt nicht
einfach alles in einer Person Umhängen
ähm ja die
Zwischenfrage stellen wenn Sie hier
heute das Leidenschaft die plädiere für
Harbeck halten wollen ja dann aber
trotzdem die Frage was ist denn gerade
positiv im Wirtschaftsministerium also
ich muss sagen bei allem womit ich mich
beschäftige ich sehe da leider nicht ich
würde ja habe gerne einen Punkt schenken
aber wir haben das Thema Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien schon
vorangebracht sie haben das Thema
wir können so viel Windkrafträder
hinbauen wie wir wollen wenn der Wind
nicht weht dann haben wir keinen Strom
und die dunkelförde kriegen wir mit Wind
auch nicht hin also ich bin anders als
sie offensichtlich für den Ausbau von
erneuerbaren Energien
natürlich brauchen wir weitere
Technologien um
auch mit den wechselnden
die sind nicht verfügbar ja deswegen
müssen wir trotzdem die erneuerbaren
Energien kommen ja nicht morgen sondern
wir haben einen Bedarf an erneuerbaren
Energien das wird ihnen auch in der
deutschen Wirtschaft überall gesagt
werden wir haben einen Bedarf an
Flexibilisierung
ich komme daher ich bin ja eigentlich
aus der Wirtschaft und erst seit kurzem
politischer seit zehn Jahren Politiker
aber nochmal zurück da haben Sie was
gemacht und ich finde man wird ja
glaubwürdiger mit den Punkten die man
hart kritisiert wie die gasumlage wenn
man sozusagen mit den anderen Punkten
dann auch versucht halbwegs hier
umzugehen jedenfalls ist das mein Stil
und bei dem würde ich auch bleiben zu
Ihrer Frage rückwirkend die Abhängigkeit
in die wir uns zum russischen
Gaslieferung gebracht haben hat viele
Ursachen aber im Kern war es falsch aber
was man jetzt ja sagen muss und das ist
Habeck er könnte auch bei Kohle
dafür sorgen dass mehr wieder ins in
Stromeinspeisung geht das sind bisher
nur zwei
Kohlekraftwerke reaktiviert da ist sein
also er redet zwar immer so aber da ist
sein Ministerium auch sehr restriktiv da
wirkst und sagte man naja für ein paar
Monate paar Monate dafür macht das
keiner also das ist ein riesen sprachen
aber nicht geliefert ja also es wird
verzögert ich weiß immer gar nicht ob er
das selber eigentlich alles mitkriegt
weil er kann nicht daran interessiert
sein dass wir in diese extreme mangele
Situationen im Winter kommen nur es gibt
halt bei den Grünen starke Kräfte die
eben dann immer davon sagen ja da müssen
wir die Nachfrage einschränken also
spricht die Industrie abkoppeln dann
reicht das für den Rest und das ist eben
ein gefährlicher Kurs
rein und da ist die Frage Herr Unlust ja
inwiefern sie jetzt mit der Krise
umgehen und wie sie sich abgeholt fühlen
als Bürger ja also viele Sachen sind ja
eigentlich für den normalen Bürger sehr
unverständlich da ist in Japan eine
Naturkatastrophe passiert die 15.000 km
von uns entfernt ist und eine
Naturgewalt ein Reaktor
zerstört hat und darauf eine Frau Merkel
entschieden hat 15000 km weiter den
Ausstieg aus der Atomenergie zu
vollziehen und das ist für mich einfach
nicht nachzuvollziehen jetzt im Moment
ist für mich nicht nachvollziehbar dass
die Grünen aus ideologischen Gründen
diesen Ausstieg aus der Kernkraft
fortführen aber gleichzeitig hoffen dass
Frankreich seine Kraftwerke wieder
hochfahren kann damit diese unseren
Energiemangel bedienen können und das
ist etwas das kann man als Normalbürger
alles gar nicht mehr nachvollziehen die
Strompreise schon weil die Auswirkungen
die merken wir als normaler Bürger
Strompreise machen wir Angst weil ich
einfach auch in der BILD lese dass es
teilweise um bis zu 15fach
gesteigert ist und ich wüsste nicht wie
ich das bezahlen sollte weil Energie ist
etwas Elementares es müsste in dem
digitalen Zeitalter von heute auch ein
Menschenrecht sein Energie zu bekommen
und wer hätte vor zehn Jahren noch
gedacht dass wir verdienen einen
trittwelt Land uns darauf vorbereiten
auf lange Blackouts also das ist in
diesem Land auch beängstigend wenn man
weiß dass man einen Moment auf den
anderen tausende Menschen in Fahrstühlen
hängen wichtig bei Medikamente zu Hause
auch nicht mehr gekühlt werden können
und es dafür überhaupt gar keine
Notfallpläne gibt also dass diese Tasten
Dinge nicht erklärt werden das ist als
Bürger erschreckend